but also for our democracy
yeah and privacy is a huge problem um
i'm pleased that you mentioned that
thank you because this will essentially
allow the government to see every single
transaction that you have ever done so
any privacy that you i think you may
still have will be utterly diminished
and you only have to look at other
things that's going on around the world
so you can look at the cypriot haircut
that happened in 2013 where those with
over 100 000 euros in their bank account
had that slashed because the eu just had
the authority to do that you look at
what's going on in lebanon where
inflation
and whether lebanese pound has lost 90
percent of its value since 2019 people
are literally banging on the doors of
the banks to try and get their money
back so your money is being confiscated
so you would be naive like i keep saying
to think that this is not coming to the
west um of course cyprus is the west but
you'd be late to think this isn't coming
to the uk what can we do right now to
make sure that these things don't happen
it's a great question and um in my
opinion this will happen just like
vaccine passports will happen and that's
fine because thankfully we have an
alternative so you have something like
bitcoin which is a deflationary asset
immune from government corruption so you
can put your money albeit of course it
is volatile but overall it does go up
and to the right um and so if you put
your money in something like that you
are entirely sovereign so that literally
means that it's non-confiscatable i for
one will not be using cbdc's when that
comes i hardly even use fiat currencies
like the pound of the us dollar i hold
my money in bitcoin and i feel safe
doing that but wait a second
when you go to a shop to buy you know a
pint of milk you're buying that in
bitcoin
so i have something called um a crypto
card so you can top up that crypto card
in bitcoin and it will just switch and
change into fiat currencies and then i
can spend it oh okay all very clever uh
leia help on uh thank you very much
indeed absolutely fascinating i hope
we'll talk to you again but halpern is
an expert on bitcoin her new book is
undressing bitcoin available on amazon
right now she was live from miami not
new york as i said earlier but she's
from miami thank you very much indeed 94